[Music]
hello everyone and welcome
to talk to you about the cloud today
we are going to talk about
identity and access management and more
generally security management
in google cloud and we will put
all that in  the context of the migration
to the cloud of fictitious companies the
fantastic knitting
so we suggest you recap
what has been seen during the previous
episodes in
particular we will focus on the
fundamentals of security, namely
identity and access management  i
'm a one year old wales cloud engineer based
in google paris i'm jean françois
macrez zyklon sultan claude based in
google paris here we go let's
start by discussing the
company policies that have been established for
the fantastic knitting that we  called
organization politicizes in English these
famous policies apply to
different levels of the organization
pains have
no corporate policy
some have thus been  é defined for
any fantastic knitting organization
others could have been applied
for project files or at the
useful level and here I am talking about resources
such as a virtual machine for example
and noted that policies apply to
your resources respecting the
inheritance logic which means that all the
machines that the knitting a fantastic
could deploy in a project will
inherit the company policies of the
folders per year and the organization for
example the prohibition to assign
public ip address to a machine
virtual machines or even allow access to
the virtual machine console
only for development and qualification environments,
care will also have been taken to group
its projects in the same folder such
as research and development where
the business entity of the machines  Sewing
good company policies is
good, but another fundamental aspect
in securing your projects
is  the management of identities and
access when granted to them or to m
yes absolutely and a good practice
that I would like to highlight here is
that he recommended using
groups rather than individual identities
also we will promote the  use
of service accounts or services is
counted exactly then its services at
40 are technical identities it can
be the identity of a virtual machine
that runs in the cloud and they
are especially recommended in a
production environment to avoid any source
of human errors
yes then moreover what we are going to do
is that we are going to associate rights
specifically to these service cons and
then in a second step we are going to
associate users with this service account
rather than
directly associate rights to them because this
kind of thing will change quite
regularly getting poorer from security vulnerabilities
now that we know the
good management practices
identities and access how
do I connect in a completely
secure way to my virtual machine which is
in the cloud good question dan and I
'm sure you have the answer absolutely and
well to connect to a
virtual machine you just have to  to start an
ssh session from cance
google cloud to authenticate we
use certificates which are
exchanged automatically when
the connection is initialized it is
also possible to allow
third-party users to access these
machines for example  we
troubleshoot
this is done by enabling the
os login feature at the vein and
making sure that those users have
compute as login permission external to
the user finally another handy bowl
when you want to access your
environments  remotely and
the use of a bastion
it is a
maximally secure virtual machine which will be the only one
reachable from your network via vpn
or other means com dedicated
interconnects once connected you
could bounce from this stronghold is
administered other machines in the
fantastic knitting park
now that we know how to
connect to our virtual machines
become secure we will attack the
next big chunk the network
exactly
so let's go to the notable points on
which I would like to come back its 1
the isolation of the resources in their
private cloud or vpc network and their
respective subnets the configuration
of the firewall with the tags and
service account 3 finally the public ip addresses
you noticed that when you
create a project with gc pays a bepc or
virtual private cloud is also created
by default it comes in very handy to
get started with google cloud and allows the
machines that are deployed to chat everything with
each other as you see
in the default firewall rules
of this bp this is of course what is not
desirable in production
so one of the first good reflexes and
to remove this vpc by funds come
by maintaining the first point in the
case of the fantastic knitting
we wanted to separate access and therefore
we created remote subnets for
the load balancers and  for web servers,
moreover, what must be understood
is that putting machines in
separate subnets makes it possible to
choose the zone in which these
machines will be deployed, this also makes it
possible to apply firewall rules
that  vary depending on the
ip address ranges associated with these his network
but this is not the best way
to isolate to completely isolate
machines from each other
you have to create different vpc in his
video on the network
alfonso showed how to use
tags to facilitate the configuration
of firewall rules both to make
this work more intuitive and to gain
flexibility taxes are very useful, however
you can sometimes  prefer
to use service accounts,
especially when you want to make
sure that only users associated with
certain specific identities will be able to
access your servers according to their
ip addresses, their tags or according to
the identity of their accounts.  service
one last thing about the network you
must not forget to
deactivate the external ip addresses of the
web servers because they are supposed to
be accessible from the internet
only through the other balance
hours and not to be published
directly on the internet
yes and by the way we talked about it
in the group instance managers video
this so let's continue our
exploration
I seem to remember that in one of the
previous episodes we explained
how to secure access to the
fantastic knitting mysql database
you have  reason and look together
how it was done
google cloud now offers in
beta version access to cloud sql in
private mode that is to say that the
database now has a
private ip address this is a private ip address
should be preferred to
limit access to the database from the application backend
it is a good security practice
is a continuation of this good
practice we have some  mentioned
another man whose video on coup
bernetti and ruled this saint jean
we indicated that we have to
specify the parameter enabled
and then alias when creating the
cluster coup bernetti this in order to
allow the workbook node to
connect to the  private ip address of
the cloud sql instance
we could have used
cloud sql proxy instead but then we would have
gone through the public ip address of the
cloud sql database
which is less secure it seems to me
that we have reached the end  of
the exploration of good
safety practices of the fantastic knitting
yes absolutely so what must be
understood is that we have approached
the fundamental aspects of the
securing an
e-commerce platform such as that of fantastic knitting
there are of course a lot of
additional ways to do it now
it's up to you to tell us if you
enjoyed this episode
and if the whole series  was
useful yes maybe you want to
go even further or
tackle other themes we will be delighted to
get back to you by then we'll tell you see you
soon see
you soon
[Music]